So last of all, we've already talked about Blueprint a little bit at the beginning of the presentation,
but it's worth circling back round to it to finish off.
I've already mentioned this, but Blueprint is an extensive suite of tools built on top of a C++ Foundation.
It allows developers, creatives, artists, designers to get stuck in and start creating things immediately.
It's built directly into the editor, meaning it can empower any member of the team,
and they can just start developing their ideas with significantly reduced iteration time.
It's great for testing out ideas and debugging them really quickly in very visual ways.
But something that's worth mentioning is that a well-structured Blueprint can and should be considered production-ready code.
Blueprint is not just for experimentation. It's not just the kind of thing that is less important than C++.
It should very much be considered that a fully-featured Blueprint is shipping-ready.
These two things are not distinct from each other.
In fact, the vast majority of Unreal games are developed with these two things in tandem,
and they both have advantages and disadvantages.
That being said, when you're developing a Blueprint, you should be making the same considerations
that you would make whenever you're working in C++.
If this isn't just iteration and exploration, and we're going for a fully-featured system,
we do need to be considering the same things.
Are the functions I'm running in this going to be killing my frame rate?
Am I doing this thing more frequently than I need to be doing it?
Is this methodology or functionality that I'm using as efficient as it could be?
Have I made good use of object-oriented principles when developing this Blueprint?
Am I jumping all over the place?
The same considerations need to be taken into account.
That being said, that's not to say there is no room for C++.
These two things are meant to communicate.
So how do we do that? How do we communicate between C++ and Blueprint?
We've already touched on this a little bit, but it's worth going back over it.
Ultimately, Blueprint is built on top of C++.
The way we expose these two things to each other, the way we expose C++ to Blueprint,
is through a set of markup that we can do via UProperties, UFunctions, and things like that.
Very, very common examples of this would be with UFunction, we have BlueprintCallable
and a BlueprintCallable function that is const or marked as BlueprintPure.
A BlueprintCallable function is a function that is intended to be called via Blueprint.
So it's C++ code that will be executed, but Blueprint can see it and call it.
An example of that would be setActorLocation on the Actor class.
A BlueprintCallable with const or BlueprintPure function works in the same way,
but it looks and executes slightly differently in Blueprint.
So that would be getActorLocation.
These are both BlueprintCallable in a sense functions, but getActorLocation is BlueprintPure.
The distinction, which is relatively obvious, being that BlueprintPure functions don't have this execution line.
Whereas setActorLocation will get executed as and when this execution line is followed here
and we hit this pin, getActorLocation is called whenever its return value
or one of its return values, if it has multiple, is referenced.
The important distinction here, and this is very important to bear in mind,
is that a normal BlueprintCallable function will cache all its output values.
So at the point that we execute this, it takes all its inputs and we cache our sweep hit result
and our return value here.
And any subsequent functions that use that data,
there will just be a cached value for each of these pins.
And unlike that, when we try and use getActorLocation,
BlueprintPure functions rerun the function every time that value is accessed.
So when we have these two print strings, because we get the output from getActorLocation twice,
getActorLocation will be run twice.
So whereas with getActorLocation it's relatively cheap, with more expensive functions,
it can be something very important to bear in mind that when you're doing something pure,
it will be rerun every time we try and use one of its outputs.
So it's a very important distinction.
But the advantage you gain is obviously it can be good for tidiness's sake,
it can be good for kind of speed's sake,
and sometimes you don't want everything on your execution path
that can make your Blueprints very, very long when they don't necessarily need to be.
Another two bits of UFunction markup that are very important to bear in mind
and you'll be using a lot are BlueprintImplementableEvent and BlueprintNativeEvent.
BlueprintImplementableEventss are essentially a little bit like notifies.
If we have some, for example, a cosmetic functionality that we want to trigger from code,
but we just kind of want to notify Blueprint that it has happened,
we can do that with a BlueprintImplementableEvent,
and then any Blueprint inheriting from that or has access to that can be notified of that.
BlueprintNativeEvent is very similar to BlueprintImplementable,
but the idea being that there is also a C++ implementation of this function.
So the way this will work is it will look for the most inherited class,
and if the Blueprint implements that event, then it will use that one,
but if there is no Blueprint implementation, it will default back to a C++ implementation.
So very, very similar, but BlueprintNative has C++.
BlueprintImplementable is Blueprint only.
It's worth highlighting as well that with BlueprintImplementableEventss,
even though your compiler or your IDE might complain that this is expecting a body,
actually it's not. Unreal will expect for BlueprintImplementableEventss
there to be no body inside your C++ code.
And this is just an example of a BlueprintImplementableEvent
that's very, very common in the editor itself, is we have BeginPlay.
Very much like normal virtual functions in C++,
BlueprintImplementableEvents and BlueprintNativeEvents,
the most inherited form, the lowest implementation in a class hierarchy of that function
will be the one that gets called, is then up to that function
to call the parent implementations if that's desired.
So with your BeginPlay, if I have a Blueprint class that inherits from a Blueprint class,
inherits from a Blueprint class, it is the bottommost child of that inheritance hierarchy
that will have its BeginPlay called.
If you want the parents to have their BeginPlay BlueprintImplementableEventss called,
then you need to call this parent BeginPlay,
and the same thing is true for BlueprintNativeEvents.
And that goes all the way back up to C++.
On the other side, with UProperties,
some examples of typical things that you might need to do.
As a programmer, we internally use C++ and Blueprints ourselves,
but a lot of the time it's about exposing functionality to design,
but also about trying to ensure that design do things in the way that you intend.
Very common uses of that might be UIMin and UIMax,
so that people can't put in ridiculous values that you don't want them to be able to use.
So if a value should only ever be between 0 and 10,
you can give it a visual that essentially gives you this kind of slider functionality,
and you can also clamp those values so that it literally will lock a value
so that it doesn't go higher or lower than two numbers that you specify.
Another thing that you might commonly want to do is use display names
so that some internal massive name can be condensed for readability
on the actual Unreal editor side of things.
And last of all, you can specify getters and setters.
So for example, if we have some kind of value,
but we want to inject some functionality on top,
this might be common for people who are used to writing C sharp,
where getters and setters are very common.
You can basically specify a function to be run
whenever we try and get this value,
and a function to be run whenever we try and set this value.
And those would look exactly like the normal get and set nodes,
but actually secretly under the hood, it's calling these functions.
So those are kind of things that you might commonly use,
but that being said, both of these things, UFunction and UProperty,
have far, far more extensive lists of things that you can do
and things that you can utilize in the objectmacros.h,
so it's worth looking up all of those.
Last of all, it's worth highlighting that
because Blueprint is a fully featured scripting language,
it also implements interfaces.
So the way we would introduce an interface at C++ level,
they can also be created in Blueprint,
there are Blueprint interfaces, but at C++ level,
is we would create an interface class,
and that would look something like this.
So if you create one through Unreal,
it will automatically generate a class that looks like this.
We have the U interface section of the class
and the I interface part of the class.
U interface is pretty much there for interaction with Blueprint,
so there's very little you need to do here,
there is just whatever you need to specify
in this U interface markup here in the macro at the top.
So for example, if you want this to be accessible by Blueprint,
you would need to add the Blueprintable markup.
And then any functions that you want to implement inside this interface
would then go in the I interface part of the interface.
And then each of these functions,
as long as this is part of a U interface class,
as long as it's a class that has that matching U interface class,
each of these functions can then have normal U function markup above it,
and all of the same U function properties will be available to you,
anything that you can do to a normal class U function you can do here.
So for example, this could be a Blueprint implementable event,
it could be a Blueprint native event, we can change the display name,
we can do any kind of meta markup there that we want to do.
It's worth highlighting as well that not all functions
inside a Blueprint interface
have to be Blueprint callable or exposed to Blueprint.
Some of them can be specifically for native,
and that's an important distinction to bear in mind
when we're talking about actually using that interface.
So the way we might utilize that in code
once we have something that implements that interface is,
well, there's really two ways.
So we can call this templated function implements,
so something that implements this interface,
we can check that through this templated function.
Here we do need to pass in the U interface type,
so the I1 will cause a compile issue,
we need to specify the U interface type,
and then that would have turned true
if this object does implement that interface.
If it does, and then we want to call functions on that,
with the U interface and the I interface,
a set of functions will be statically generated
that you then statically call
through the I version of the interface.
So I my interface, and as you can see,
we had this some Blueprint implementable function,
we call execute, we get the static version of the interface,
execute underscore and then the function name.
Because this function takes two parameters,
we can see those are passed in here and here,
the first parameter of this static version of the function
takes in the actual object that you're calling it on.
So as you can see, because it's static,
there is no concept of the object we're calling it on,
so the first parameter is which object am I calling this function on.
The alternative and the kind of more,
the way that you might assume to do it in C++ more naturally
is to just cast that object using the I version of the interface
to check whether or not that interface,
whether or not it's null, and if it's not null,
we would go inside this if statement body.
That's absolutely fine, but it's worth bearing in mind,
and very important to bear in mind,
that when you cast to an interface in this way,
that will tell you whether or not
that object implements that interface,
but if you have functions that are implemented in Blueprint,
those will not get detected when you try and call them,
and that can lead to a lot of very frustrating and slow debugging.
Native functions and natively implemented functions
for that interface will work absolutely fine,
but if you have functions that are either Blueprint implementable
or Blueprint native, it simply won't see those.
So if you had a Blueprint native function,
it would probably call the C++ version of that function,
but even if you're calling on a Blueprint
that overrides that functionality,
it would probably just call the C++ native version of the function
and not the Blueprint implementation.
So if you have anything that is Blueprint implementable
or Blueprint native, unfortunately,
using this casting to the interface is not going to be suitable.
In short, Blueprint is an incredible tool
and should be used to its fullest extent,
and it should be very much considered
as something that is in tandem with C++.
We use both of these things together,
and they both have their advantages.
Again, incredibly fast iteration times,
visual debugability with Blueprints,
it can sometimes actually be much easier to see execution paths in real time
rather than having to stop everything with breakpoints
and step through your code.
You can watch it all happening as it's running.
Where C++, slightly more performant,
access to the full range of all the Unreal Engine code base
and increased debugability
when you get into the fine-grained things
like really needing to see every variable
and things like your call stack.
So wrapping up, we're just going to talk a little bit
about some of the resources that we've got available to us.
Obviously, this has been a bit of a whirlwind exploration
of a lot of the basic fundamentals.
If you want to follow up on any of this,
we have Unreal Engine documentation at unrealengine.com.
We have the Unreal Engine YouTube channel.
We have a Twitch.
UDN is the Unreal Developer Network.
This is dedicated for Unreal Engine licensees,
so you would need to be a licensee to have access to this.
But if that's not available to you,
then we do still have the AnswerHub,
which is essentially a little bit like Quora or Yahoo Answers,
but specifically around Unreal.
Very, very active community there,
really good for looking for people
who might have already stumbled across the same issue as you.
And then last of all, we have the Unreal Engine Community Wiki,
where people have hosted up a whole load of different kinds of tutorials
that have come more from the community side
than official Epic stuff.
So I think that's everything.
It's a lot to cover, and it's a lot to take in.
Like I said, this has been a very, very shallow view
of all of these things,
but it's just good to have this kind of broad understanding
of a lot of these different systems and functionalities
when you're coming to Unreal for the first time.
Maybe not all of this sticks the first time,
might need a couple of rewatches,
but hopefully we've just planted enough seeds
that next time you kind of come across something,
you might be like, oh yeah, I think I remember something about that.
Hopefully this has been useful.
Thanks very much for watching, and see you next time.